a lot of people think i got the worst
room in the house
and let me show you why i think that is
incorrect and i actually got the best
room
i am the only one that gets my own
bathroom so this is a vanity that i can
do my makeup on and then i have my own
shower and toilet area
i also get a walk-in closet so i have
all this space for all my clothes even
though i don't have that many
i also have a window seat that overlooks
the backyard and
a second floor in my room i'm gonna show
you the upstairs and it's bigger than
everyone else's
and just so you guys can see this is the
room from the view of the upstairs
so the first part of my loft is right
here it's pretty plain but as you can
see i have a lot of space and i can do a
lot with that
then if i walk over this way i have a
whole studio
to myself that i get to create content
in which is what i love
to do and behind the curtain there's
even more space
one other secret behind my room is that
behind this curtain there's a tunnel